digamos que alguien te pregunta 50
/
en 35
es igual
a este espacio en blanco
como puedes pensar esto en términos de
un problema de multiplicación bien
entonces cualquier número que esté en
este espacio en blanco
al multiplicarlo por 5
debe de dar como resultado
es decir cuántas veces 5 es igual a 50 y
eso es 10 10 por 5 es igual a 50 por lo
que 50 dividido entre 5 es igual a 10 y
creo que aquí vemos la relación 50 entre
5 es igual a 10 10 por 5 es igual a 50
10 por 5 es igual a 50 y podemos hacerlo
de otra manera 50
dividido entre 10 cuánto será 50
dividido entre 10 pues es igual a 5
y como yo sé eso -ha bueno pues lo sé
porque 5
multiplicado 5
por 10
esto que está aquí 5 x 10 es igual a 50
y sigamos pensando en esto qué tal si
otra persona ahora te pregunta bueno
este número que está en este espacio
blanco si lo divido
es igual
a 9 como sabré qué número es este que
está en el espacio en blanco o sea que
el número dividido entre 2 es igual a 9
y podemos utilizar lo que vivimos aquí
arriba que 50 entre 5 es igual a 10 o
sea que 10 por 5 es igual a 50 por lo
que 9 por 2 es decir 9 por 2
debe de ser igual al número que está en
el espacio en blanco
pero esto ya lo conocemos 9 por 2 es
igual a 18 por lo que este espacio en
blanco debe de ser igual a 18
18 entre 2 es igual a 9 y esto sólo
revela cómo están relacionados los
números es decir 9 veces 2 es igual a 18
o dos veces 9 es igual a 18 también sea
18 lo divido entre 2 obtengo 9 o si
tengo 9 grupos de dos objetos tengo 18
objetos es decir 9 por 2 es 18 o también
puedes decir 18 entre 2 es igual a 9
bien
abraham digamos que otra persona te
pregunta en qué 12
dividido entre este espacio en blanco un
número en este espacio en blanco esto es
igual
a 3
es decir tres por este número que está
en el espacio en blanco es igual a 12 a
ver pongamos aquí 3
por este espacio en blanco un número que
va en este espacio
esto es igual a 12 igual a 12 entonces 3
porque me da 12 bueno eso ya lo
conocemos 3 por 4 es igual a 12 por lo
que 12 entre 4 es igual a 3